vous savez j'aime on marche on a
construit une belle famille on s'entend
très bien
en fait il n'y a qu'une chose qui a
jamais vraiment marché entre nous tel
sexe je ne désire pas alors mon mari
pense que j'ai un problème que je suis
coincé qu'il faut absolument que j'aille
consulter moi je pense juste que c'est
pas mon truc et des femmes pour qui
c'est important le sexe et pour d'autres
fins et pas important et je vais partie
de cette catégorie là enfin c'est ce que
j'ai pensé
les années ont passé
on s'en est plus ou moins accommoder
jusqu'au jour où jusqu'au jour où j'ai
rencontré un homme un homme avec qui je
m'entends extrêmement bien un homme que
j'admire
un homme pour qui j'éprouve un désir fou
un homme avec qui je me sens tellement
femmes et ça va je suis pas en train de
vous raconter ma vie parce que là il y
en a qui flippe dans la salle vaincu pas
de ma famille à mes amis
non je suis pas en train de vous
raconter ma vie quoique simplement ce
que j'ai en train de vous dire ce soir
c'est mot pour mot ce que les femmes ont
le plus confié dans le secret de mon
cabinet oui je vois des femmes infidèles
il avoue ni comment mais c'est un truc
d'hommes blancs finalité c'est bien
connu ils ont ça dans le sens et gince
et dans leurs gènes ils sont beaucoup
plus à ridelles que les femmes
absolument pas parce que les femmes sont
les championne toute catégorie de la
culpabilité
elle pense toujours que quand il ya un
problème dans leur couple c'est de leur
faute
elle pense évidemment que ce il
n'éprouve pas de désir sexuel envers
leur mari qu'elle aime
elle devrait vrai désir produit par
définition
et bien c'est à cause d'elle c'est parce
qu'elles sont coincées
elle pense aussi que du coup elle n'ose
pas par rapport à la culpabilité elle
n'ose pas du coup dire alors mari ce qui
ne va pas par peur de blesser
elles ont peur de blesser l'autre elle
préfère du coup les petits mensonges
plutôt que de dire une vérité blessant
en fait en réalité elles ont peur de se
sentir responsable du malheur de celui
qu'elle aime il n'y a pas meilleur
terrain pour y développer une relation
extraconjugale
parce que la relation extra conjugale
c'est d'abord et avant tout une histoire
de mensonge mais la vérité la vérité de
ces femmes qu'elles n'osent pas dire à
leur mari elle est très simple et moi je
vais vous le dire
chérie tu ne me fait pas rêver
mais c'est aux rites qui est notre truc
pareil à l'homme qu'on aime vous tire
tout sera toujours moins terriblement
terrible ou douloureux pour lui que le
jour où il vous surprend en train de
fuir dans les bras d'un autre
aucune commune mesure vraiment croyez
moi pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle de
leur fidélité la fidélité des femmes une
certaine cause de l'infidélité que je
vois depuis que j'ai ouvert mon cabinet
je ne sais pas pour quelle raison je
n'ai que des femmes infidèles
j'ai dû avoir peut-être cinq hommes
infidèles à tout casser non j'ai eu que
des femmes pourquoi je vous parle de ça
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il me semble que
cette expérience dit quelque chose de
notre société depuis plus d'un demi
siècle
les féministes ont envoyé balader les
blanche neige est belle au bois dormant
pour nous encourager nous les femmes à
devenir actrice notre propre vie
j'adhère complètement au projet mais
quand on y pense un petit peu ces
princesses elle était éveillé au désir
par le baiser d'un prince d'impro
chevalier d'un homme qui avait bravé
tous les dangers qui avait tué dragon un
homme qui est investi d'une place dans
notre société
un homme qui se bat pour une noble cause
un homme qui monte à cheval qui
courageux qui aventurier et qui
certainement a des abdos sublime j'en
suis sûr ils n'ont jamais montré chez
disney j'en suis sûr avec solidarité
masculine à mon avis bien sûr juste
petite parenthèse sur les abdos fallait
que je vous le dise parce que on prend
encore à notre époque que nous les
femmes le plus important c'est le charme
non pas spécialement
d'accord un beau corps ça peut aider
aussi partager les femmes en
consultation qui viennent me voir dit
voilà je vous vois pas ce que je désire
pas mon mari je me amenez moi votre mari
le mari arrivent mais madame je
comprends tout va bien c'est pas bien de
dire ça mais bon j'ai a hérité quoi et
puis je peux dire mais madame ok vous ne
désirez pas votre mari bon d'accord
j'entends bien mais est-ce que les
autres femmes de daisy à votre mari
blanc vertement voulait le désir et si
les eaux ne le désirent pas non il vaut
mieux comprendre un truc que ce soit
bien clair c'est que l'on désire aussi
une personne quand d'autres personnes
qu'on valorise qu'on admire nous montre
que cette personne là est quelqu'un de
bien et de dia mais le problème quand on
se marie et fier quand il marie tu
t'habilles super bien tu es magnifique
temps est magnifique
pourquoi tu es magnifique tu dis à tout
le monde et locke et la sublime
eh bien c'est fini les gars vous pouvez
plus le désirez pourquoi parce qu'il est
à moi ok et pareil l'homme fait la même
chose j'ai indique à toute ma communauté
que je sors du champ de la séduction que
maintenant je suis le mari de la femme
de et le futur père de mes enfants et en
un coup l'autre perd son pouvoir
d'attraction
si je suis de cette manière là je ne
viens plus un homme plus à part entière
une chose quand même important de savoir
je veux faire ma parenthèse attendait ou
est-ce que j'en étais avec mes
princesses
je reviens les françaises et les
français ça raconte d'accord mais
princesse à la con mais quand même elle
se tape des mecs qui ont la gueule elle
alors que nous comment dire l'idée c'est
que elle se tape des mecs qui ont de la
gueule et pas des gentils petits mari
qui change des couches de leur bébé qui
passent l'aspirateur à 5 heures de
l'après midi tandis en double qui vont
marcher dire chérie je vais acheter des
légumes pour nous cuisiner de bons
petits lapins mais surtout pas de viande
parce que tuer les animaux ça leur fait
mal
des dragons qui tu es à nos princes
n'empire par mois pour les hommes qui
par leur bébé en écharpe
on n'a jamais jusqu'à présent dans
l'espèce humaine des femmes être
émoustillé par des hommes qui son père
au foyer ça marche pas comme ça
papa alors gilbert le problème que dans
trois provinces sont là donc le désir
marche pas de cette manière là mais vous
savez le problème est le drame dans
cette histoire et je le pense pour tous
les hommes qui sont là c'est que c'est
nous qui l'avons voulu le coût de leur
bébé en écharpe ainsi trop mignon c'est
nous qui leur demandons et c'est nous
qui le regrettent
ces princesses ne sont pas non plus
éveillés par le départ le baiser d'un
macho de marie qui violente et mépris
d'une femme par manque cruel de
confiance enduits et les problèmes c'est
que les hommes d'aujourd'hui tombe bien
souvent dans ces deux écueils entre le
gentil mari et le match mais ils ne
savent pas toujours très bien comment se
situer le problème c'est que les femmes
en souffrent on a voulu l'égalité mais
on apprenait bien souvent leur
différenciation on sait viriliser et on
les a déstabilisés ils ne nous font plus
rêver et l'union sexuelle entre un homme
et une jeune femme en est menacé
il s'est quand même c'est le meilleur
truc à vie sur terre pour qu'une union
sexuelle pourquoi je parle de l'union
sexuelle l'intimité sexuelle c'est parce
qu'il me semble que nous voyons là
l'illustration peut-être la plus
parfaite d'une mixité heureuse pour que
cette communion des personnes puissent
exister pour que cet accord entre deux
êtres si différents soit possible il
faut au préalable deux identités
distincts construite assumer et
affirmées sinon on prend le risque de la
fusion la fusion c'est extrêmement
réconfortant c'est un et 1 ne font plus
quand c'est trop beau
oui mais lequel des deux qui dit fusion
dit toujours destruction l'un aspire
l'autre et asphyxient on peut plus
respirer et un beau jour dans ce genre
de couple on se réveille on ne sait plus
qu'il y en ait mais en fait parce qu'on
n'a jamais su qui on était parce qu'au
lieu de se poser la question s'est mis
en couple dans l'espoir que le couple me
donne une raison d'exister donne un sens
à mon existence
c'est une impasse si j'ai pas une
identité construite cette relation cette
mixité les dangereuses
parce que je ne peux pas m'affirmer
devant l'autre et ces lieux que je
deviens la gentille fille qui n'est pas
blessé son mari et le gentil garçon qui
fait tout pour plaire à sa femme parce
que je fais tout ça dans l'espoir que
l'autre me confirme que je suis
quelqu'un d'aimable je perds ma liberté
dans la fusion ce face à face n'est plus
possible et le désir c'est un pour qu'on
puisse construire son identité
il faut d'abord prendre un temps un
temps particulier où on se pose des
grandes questions sur sa propre vie
construire une identité demande d'abord
de savoir ce qui m'a été transmis quel
est l'héritage que j'ai reçu laissons
les valeurs que j'ai reçu quels sont les
piliers dans ma vie l'héritage la
transmission du savoir qui je suis si je
ne sais pas d'où je viens je ne veux pas
savoir où je vais première étape une
deuxième étape de la construction de son
identité c'est la confrontation à soi
même ça ne peut se vivre que dans
l'expérience de la solitude solitude ce
n'est pas elle visuellement solitude
c'est être en dialogue aussi avec soi
même
quelles sont mes grands rêves
quelles sont mes passions mes sources
d'entousiasme qu'est ce que j'ai envie
de réaliser sur cette terre qu est-ce
que j'ai d'unique à offrir au monde mais
aussi quels sont les blessures dans ma
vie et en quoi je peux les convertir
pour qu'elles soient des forces et
qu'elle porte du fruit là où je suis
enfin nous avons besoin aussi que
quelqu'un vienne nous confirmer dans ce
que nous sommes la confirmation viendra
pas d'un petit copain une petite copine
ça viendra de quelqu'un qui est déjà
bien installée dans sa vie dans sa vie
d'homme sa vie de femme sa vie d'adulte
et qui me dit tu est une belle personne
vas-y lance toi alors quel programme
valencia c'est un programme magnifique
qui est important de vivre
alors il ya un temps particulier
privilégié pour vivre ce temps de co2
pour apprendre à se connaître pour
ensuite savoir comment servir
comment mieux aimer l'autre et bien ce
temps on peut présupposer que le temps
de l'adolescence serait le temps idéal
alors si c'est le temps idéal et si nous
souhaitons dans notre société une mixité
heureuse et que nous savons que pour que
cette mixité puisse exister il faut que
chacun puisse aussi construire son
identité
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour mettre dans
les établissements scolaires des
ateliers de développement personnel ou
les adolescents et enfants peuvent
apprendre à se connaître mais aussi mais
aussi quand allons nous proposer
d'autres expériences aux jeunes que
juste bourrer la gueule et se faire
faire une fellation par leurs copines
pour devenir un homme ou une femme
on doit proposer des expériences fort
des tours du monde des voyages des
sommets ce que vous voulez mais qui
construisent aussi équipe arrivait un
dépassement et apprendre à se connaître
quelle expérience en propose qui nous
permet de nous construire la troisième
chose aussi
c'est enfin l'on nous proposait enfin
dans les écoles dès le plus jeune âge
des cours de philosophie pour faire
aimer la vérité aux jeunes pour leur
faire aimer la sagesse mais russe que
quand même sympa cette brume ou twitter
mais je le vois pas ce que la lumière
c'est clair en vain sur public je vois
votre pâte et vous n'avez pas tout à
fait l'air d'adolescents et peut-être
que certains d'entre vous c'est 10
elle est mignonne pour papa seriate
éducatif une question je me suis proposé
alors comment on fait no stress
notre société a inventé un truc
formidable qui s'appelle donc en fait
j'ai rendez vous parce que ça s'appelle
la tout formidable ce qui est génial
c'est une session de rattrapage pour
tous que tous ceux qui auraient séché
programme à l'adolescence ça s'appelle
la crise de la quarantaine
c'est la même chose avec une carte bleue
en main comme différence presti
l'adolescence avec une carte bleue est
génial mais je dirais que je rajouterais
avec trois gamins en mariant plus d'un
petit peu plus complexe pour se poser
ces questions sur soi et on se rend
compte que c'est risqué
ok c'est risqué mais ce risque vaut la
peine d'être repris l'essentiel ce n'est
pas d'être en couple pour le couple
l'essentiel c'est d'apprendre à gagner
en liberté intérieure et de vivre cette
sagesse aussi
et on ne peut pas se furent
éternellement prenez ce risque de vous
poser ces questions là que vous penserez
aussi
vous entendez bien pour tout ce que je
vous dis que cette mixité heureuse et
tous les discours qui ont été promenés
aujourd'hui sur le féminisme l'égalité
elle suppose d'abord qu'on construise la
question de l'identité
sans quoi tous ces discours sonne creux
et il me semble encore une autre chose
vraiment importante que je voudrais que
vous pensiez ce soir
si je vous dis ça avec autant de
conviction c'est que depuis pas mal
d'années maintenant je viens plan ma
vocation de femmes
ma vocation de que j'ai toujours pensé
voilà parle d'amour sexualité partouche
donne beaucoup de conférences et à
chaque fois les gens me posent la même
question et votre mari
ça va tu pas très bien comment je dois
prendre mais je vais vous répondre une
chose eh ben c'est pas facile tous les
jours
c'est pas facile de faire passer tous
les jours de faire face à une femme qui
essaie de vis et de liberté et qui vit à
plein sa vocation
moi j'ai une chose qui me vient en tête
après vous avoir tout écouter la liberté
c'est beau l'égalité c'est bien on est
tous d'accord mais si ce n'est pas pour
aimer et être aimé ça ne sert à rien
c'est ce qu'on veut au plus profond de
nous c'est l'amour et il faut que cette
liberté cette égalité soit au service de
nos amours que nous puissions enfin nous
aimer et être aimé et si enfin on
prenait ce temps aussi avec les hommes
parce qu'ils ont les mêmes défis de
gagner en liberté pour qu'il puisse se
construire être assumée dans une
virilité qui est belle dans le bon sens
du terme la virilité de savoir qui on
est de savoir où on va d'avoir confiance
en soi et d'être assumée et bien enfin
si on s'attaque à âmes sur ces
questions-là enfants yves ce seront
peut-être de vouloir de nous dominer et
ils seront enfin nous sublimer merci